des deux vieux sur un banc public toi
ils savent ils sont un petit peu
alzheimer et il ya un commerçant
ambulant au loin tu te sois et le
tchadien sauvage et dit tiens je
mangerais bien une grasse fatwa à l'oti
dit oui bonne idée une glace oui bombe a
dit je vais y aller tu veux quoi toi et
du coup tu moi j'ai bonne chose que la
pistache et 10 et toi moi je prends
vanille fraise le d'hiddink note le
quand même c'est que l'un peu perdu la
boule c'est mieux que du neuf des dix ça
va chocolat pistache vanille fraise aux
deux heures après il revient avec deux
dogues ce qui a laissé sur le mot est
dit et la moutarde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces espaces place vendôme à paris place
vendôme à paris place vendôme les
bijoutiers tout ça ouais ya un énorme
camion noir qui arrive il se gare devant
chez cartier le hayon des camions
s'ouvre et il ya un éléphant énorme qui
descend à reculons comme ça à peine
sorti fonce sur la vitrine de chez
cartier la défense crypte et avec sa
trompe public tous les bijoux et en mon
nom le camion le rayon se ferment et le
cas mûri par vent arrière brigadier de
gendarmerie qui arrivent sur les lieux
le seul témoin
c'est un petit garçon de café qui était
en train d'installer sa terrasse toi le
matin lors il divo dit qu'est ce que
j'ai vu il dit j'ai vu un gros camion
noir à ya un éléphant est descendu à
péter vitrines ou des déchets gardien
puis qui avait joué aux motos et camions
et des bus et des tribulations d'un
camion le dily c'est une blague ou quoi
c'était tellement spectaculaire j'ai pas
pensé une seconde à noter numéro du
vieux camions man vingt dix quand même
la marque du camion ont dit j'en sais
rien c'était un gros camion noir et or
était de me casser
comment ça se met en colère
dimon avait dit quand même
l'éléphant c'est un éléphant d'asie
connais les faux d'afrique via les
j'habite à sarcelles moitié du sénat
vous savez très bien
quels éléphants d'afrique qui l'a dit
grunge oreilles l'éléphant d'asie
il a des pas qui serait bien le garçon
est dit balla je peux pas vous dire
il avait une cagoule
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le patron bas il a recommencé la fois
depuis des mois je vous en raconte une
petite scie s'agit dit il arrive au bar
entendu partie tu dois te fais ça
horrible de vieillir rappel du [ __ ] le
singe et neuf branches et diouf garçon
faisait débat n'a jamais repris depuis
le début ce sens
[Rires]
c'est une blague qui fonctionne sur la
répétition signale encore elle commence
vraiment
bon alors oprean se trouve que ces jours
là c'est deux petits singes il arrive
aux morts il s'accroche et dieu garçons
vous avez des madame claudine on n'a pas
de bananes déjà j'ai dit vous savez des
ménages dit non à je viens de vous dire
je n'avais pas de bananes s'agit dit il
avait des ménages dieu pro ne vendent
encore une fois si j'ai des malaises je
te tire la langue
la conque ou pelé mission et on lance la
pga
[Applaudissements]
jeudi il lui dit tu me demande encore
une fois si j'étais malade je tire la
langue
je vais à coup sûr le comptoir ils
veulent me disant j'ai dit vous avez des
clous mais j'ai dit non j'ai pas de
clous
alors vous avez des ménages
[Applaudissements]